okay um oh good timing
game is beginning um
what round is this
this is round ten so the penultimate
round
london time
we're playing a main line this is a main
main line
measure b5
i have a feeling black doesn't know the
theory here
a lot of people play asics who don't
know what they're doing and then they
walk into a trap um
it's playable though okay this is
basically the
the main idea is queen a3 move
the gamer bits yeah as opposed to the
gambits
so
wow there's there's some nice
possibilities here
i'm thinking i can
maybe even win two pawns i'll start by
taking and the knight g5
i mean all the pawns are hanging
like so many things attacked
it's a nice london line i mean this is
one of the points of bishop e5 is
um to really damage the queen side
so there's a line f5 and then
i take with rook or knight maybe take
with knight attack the rook
and then later take the pawn okay now my
knight's attacked
oh this is maybe trickier than
actually maybe i can take the pawn first
defending the knight through x-ray
vision
this is a funny move it doesn't work
though
maybe i should have taken the
h7 pawn first
man i want to do like weird things but
for example rook h5 is kind of
intriguing
i shouldn't spend so much time looking
at it but it's so intriguing
now rook h5 queen dix queen what am i
thinking
if i take the queen first
it's really a debate between taking or
knight h3
yeah probably not sure
probably taking the queen and now knight
h3 and
okay i'm up upon b4 looks nice
or preventing c5
and really trying to fix both pawns
yeah the bishop is going to find some
life on this diagonal
i'm realizing my knight should be on b2
to prepare how do i get to b2
via d1
but then maybe via f2
let's start with g4 and f3 and then
maybe mine i can maneuver
g4 also just preparing g5
yeah this should be pretty
straightforward
but you never know
okay let's start with g5 this will be a
nice transformation
i work h2 preparing the double up
if king g8 i still play rogue h1 because
takes i made on h8
and maybe i can even throw in g4
to then take and later play g5
that's really not pleasant for black
interesting so maybe now i can take
because the pawn is eventually going to
have to take king takes i had rook h1
now this pawn is forever a weakness
the question is how to how to progress
rook h5 maybe can like zigzag my way
to victory
i just want to infiltrate
some g4 move
g4 is kind of interesting
maybe i'll start i'm going to start with
king here king's more useful closer to
the
kingside pawns
and then here preparing this move
is f6 coming
f6 i can play that at 4 rook h5
is risky
i should not have allowed this
i want to play this in meat
wow i'm winning black can't stop rook b6
wow i won that what a crazy game
man i somehow won that
i i had just a nice advantage i let it
slip i was probably losing at some point
oh sorry i forgot to turn on the board
sounds
uh okay sounds are back
hold the game
what a game man
i really let things slip i threw is not
a good move
i should have been a bit more patient
oh thanks toggy for the win bits
at some point toggy cheered the next
game win bits this was this was one of
the next games
i was um how many moves was that oh it
was 16 nine moves
yeah it's a move list
oh and thank you do belize zigzag
oh yeah i zigzagged my way to victory
towards the end there with the king i
was such an awkward position because uh
the king
rook and knight they were all kind of
scattered and i had to be careful not to
get forked or skewered
this is tricky if i take the pawn
there's um queen h4
so i had to kind of walk around this way
and then i wasn't sure what i was going
to do if black just
pushes
because my king can't cross maybe here
and here
black's probably winning here
queen b5 mates wait what
oh queen g5 me final position i've seen
in a while
my opponent missed maiden one queen g5
but yeah this final position is really
nice because the queen can't check my
king effectively
and this can't be stopped like the
queen's so out of it
what a game
oh opponent says good game oh good game
to my opponents